Welcome to Academy
Dialogues, It Starts With Us.
My name is Shawn Finnie.
We are continuing our ongoing
series of conversations
about race, ethnicity,
history, opportunity,
and the art of filmmaking.
Today's discussion
group will explore
the invisibility of
Latinos in Hollywood,
the complexity of
Latin identity,
legacies of colonialism,
and solutions
to advance representation.
Moderating today's
conversation is Lorenza Muñoz.
EVP, Member Relations and
Awards at the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences.
Victoria Alonso, EVP
Production Marvel Studios.
Casting Director
Producer Carmen Cuba.
Director, Nadia Hallgren.
Actress, producer,
director, and businesswoman
Eva Longoria, and marketing
strategist Yvette Rodriguez.
We look forward to your
conversation today.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome  It's so
wonderful to have you all here.
It's such a dream for
me to be able to host
this conversation that
is absolutely necessary
and I think we're all going to
really enjoy and commune over.
So without much further
ado, let's get started.
So tell us, what brought
you to Hollywood?
What was your story?
And what have you
faced along the way?
Let's start with Eva.
Of course, you start
with me as my son
is marching through the room.
Mama loves you.
So yeah, my gosh my journey
has been a long one.
I never wanted to be an actor.
I didn't even know
about the industry.
I grew up in Corpus
Christi, Texas.
And we had a TV.
We didn't even go to the
movies because it was just
too expensive.
We would go to
the dollar cinemas
which were the movies
that were out already
for a very long time.
So that was the closest as I
got to experience in Hollywood.
But I don't know what happened.
I went to college and one day I
said, I'm going to be an actor.
And I told my mom,
I said, I think
I'm going to become an actor and
move to LA with $200 in my bank
account and went and got a job.
I just figured it out.
I figured out I think my
journey to today, which is more
directing and producing.
People who think I'm an actor
turned director-producer
but I always tell people, I
was always a director producer
who happened to fall
into acting as a means
to the end of
becoming a director.
But for me it's just been--
it's been a fun journey
because I remember
arriving in Hollywood and
not being Latina enough,
because I didn't speak Spanish
and I didn't have an accent.
And every audition I
went on they were like,
could you do it more
like Rosie Perez?
And I was like, well, I don't--
I'm not from New York.
I'm not Puerto Rico, and
I got a specific dialect.
And then-- and I
didn't speak Spanish.
I couldn't go out in Spanish
language things either.
So I wasn't Latin enough and
then I wasn't white enough,
and so I got Italian roles.
I was Eva Longoria.
I was like, great, I'll take it.
I will do that role
for a long time.
And what it made me realize
in the industry was obviously
stereotypes and what people
think a Latina should sound
like or look like.
But also, that Hollywood
thought we were monolithic.
That there's not Afro-Latinos.
That we're all of one sexuality.
That we are all supposed to be
gorgeous and sexy and feisty.
I remember I kept
getting a note when
I was on Young and the Restless,
could you do it more Latina?
And I'm like, I am Latina.
Like I can't do it any more
Latina because I am Latina.
And so there was a big learning
curve for our industry.
And I think that
today people always
go, how are we doing today?
And I said, we're facing
the right direction now.
I don't know we've taken enough
steps in the right direction,
but at least we're facing
the right direction
and we're having these
conversations, which
is really important.
That's wonderful, yeah.
And as you can see from
our beautiful panel
how different we all are
and we are all Latinos.
It's wonderful our diversity.
Victoria Alonso.
Gosh, I don't know.
I was never supposed
to be in Hollywood.
I grew up in Argentina,
born and raised.
I'm a teenager of the military
dictatorship where I always say
that the theater saved my life.
So-- because instead
of being in marches
I was at the theater
playing, rehearsing,
and I was very involved
in the marches.
So I often have told
the story of how
I used to hold the
banners in the front row.
I know that's a surprise.
And because the banners
were so heavy we ended up--
I ended up like staying
back two or three rows.
But when they shot, they
shot at the first row
and the second row.
And by the time that the
third row was about to be hit
we had a chance to run.
So all that to say that when
I wanted to study something
I studied theater and
psychology because that's
what my father was.
And that was a chance for
me to get close to him
and he died at the age of 40.
So he died young when
I was
When I came to The
States I had never
thought that I would
be in production.
And I had-- in LA
I have three jobs.
And I worked at Alaska
Airlines at 5:00
in the morning, 5:00 to
12:00 for a long time.
And then I will go to Paramount
Pictures to be a page.
And I did all the live shows.
And then now during
the weekends I
would have a Black
Angus waitress job.
This is with-- I had a full
college education already
finished, but I was trying to
figure out what I was doing.
And I tell you the
Alaska Airlines story
because I think is important.
A friend of mine
at Alaska Airlines
said, hey, I think you'll
be great in production.
And I'm like, what is
production because I was doing--
I was helping
produce a show called
Frida Kahlo at the Bilingual
Foundation of the Arts.
And she said, I
have a there that
works in production you
should meet with her.
So I got to meet with Carla and
she gives me my first PA job.
That to say from there on
that was almost 30 years ago.
But when we did Captain Marvel
I worked at Alaska Airlines
and I didn't want to
ask my mother for money.
So I had the three jobs and
I had jobs that gave me food.
Alaska Airlines gave me the
leftover food from first class
because they threw it away, I
ate it daily and I took a home.
Then I would go to the shows,
the live shows at Paramount.
They fed all of us.
That was beautiful.
I ate at night.
And on the weekends--
I'm Argentinian
no denying there.
I ate steak at Black
Angus for a reduced price.
When we did Captain
Marvel, Alaska airlines
had a couple of planes
with Captain Marvel on it.
And I remember being in a
marketing meeting and I saw it,
and I just that--
I said nothing, I was just--
my tears were coming down.
What full circle to those days?
Look, I'm talking about
a plane and here is
the Santa Monica Airport
gives us the plane q sound.
I love it.
This is a great time.
I remember thinking if you would
have written it there's-- they
would have said, no
that's a little too much.
That you go from--
that you go from eating the food
and working at Alaska Airlines
to having eat--
their plane having our film.
That was one of the pinnacles
alongside with Black Panther.
I always say this,
pinnacles of my career.
So from production
from PA to now
Alongside with Louis
Kevin heading the studio,
I'm on my 30th Marvel
film and my eight--
as in eighth streaming show
and second animation show.
So we-- anyway, long
story to tell you there.
Amazing trajectory and game
changing, what you've done.
Nadia Hallgren, tell
us about your journey.
Wow.
So my journey--
I still don't feel Hollywood.
I feel like documentary.
I never imagined being
a documentary filmmaker
would land me somehow
anywhere near Hollywood.
I'm born and raised
in South Bronx
and I started to be
interested in documentary
through a community
photography program
that my mom encouraged me to go
to at the International Center
Photography.
And it just really
stirred up this interest
in the storytelling and
gave me an opportunity
to try and make sense of
the world that I love them.
And then I started
making short films
and through the biggest
stroke of luck in my life
I met one of Michael
Moore's producers
at a community film
festival in the Bronx.
And she gave me--
her name Tia
Lessin-- she gave me
my very first job
as a PA as well,
which is, I always think those
are great stories working
on Fahrenheit 9/11.
And at that point,
I decided that I
wanted to be a cinematographer.
I felt like being DP
gave me an opportunity
to not have to speak.
I could show up on set
I could be quiet and not
have to expose my--
what I thought was
my lack of education
or that I came from the hood.
Before I worked in film
I was a nightclub bouncer
and I worked my way up
started working as a DP
and then ultimately started
directing documentaries,
and that's why I'm here.
Awesome.
I love that you were a bouncer.
So cool.
You know me.
So you can probably
now imagine that.
Sure there's a thousands
stories that we
can hear from you even though--
Yeah, so we could just do
the whole thing on that.
Oh, my God.
Listen, that's a good
documentary too Nadia.
It is.
I love it.
Carmen Cuba, tell us your story.
Yeah, well, like most of us
so far this was not my plan.
My father is Peruvian and was a
political economist for the UN
growing up.
And my mom is American of
Dutch and Italian descent.
And was a Spanish teacher
who started her connection
to Latin-America at 15 when
she was an exchange student.
She was a-- she had
skipped various grades
and she was an exchange
student college in Colombia.
So my two parents met
both being fluent speaker.
Well, my father was
not a fluent American--
English speaker but my
mother spoke Spanish fluently
and they met in college
and had me and I
lived between Peru and
Bolivia very, very immersed.
Peru Bolivia and
eventually New Mexico,
but I was very immersed
in a world that
was surrounded by people from
all over the world from birth.
Many of my parent's colleagues
were from all over the world.
I went to an international
school in Bolivia.
So my first friends
were African.
And anyway that's just
to say that at the stage
was set for me to explore and
be very interested in humans
from all different backgrounds,
from myself and have--
I come from-- a great
respect for that idea
of authentic diversity in the
lives that we actually live.
And when I moved to
the states I moved to--
when I was around 11--
I moved to New Mexico, which
is another very complicated
ethnic mix.
And there my mom
got me involved in--
like Nadia your mom--
my mom got me involved
in a bilingual theater group.
And it was one of only three
in the country at the time.
And it was run by an openly gay,
Puerto Rican, HIV positive man.
And so that was my--
and he was in New Mexico
trying to tell these stories
with non-professional actors.
He was trying to start a real
community theater company.
A lot of it focusing on who are
new Mexicans and who are we.
So in that, I ran lights, I
did sound, I was on stage,
I was one of only
two kids because it
was all-- it was really adults.
So I came up through that.
All the while thinking
I needed to have
a real job when I grew up.
So I went into journalism and
I studied journalism and then
from there I was a news
reporter on Univision.
Back when there were only
three channels in New Mexico
and only one of them
was Spanish speaking.
So I did that and
then I came to--
but actually when I was
doing that I realized that I
love people and I love stories.
And doing news you only got
sort of, this accident happened.
Here's the person.
Who, what, where, when, why.
And I always wanted to follow
those people home and a month
later and be like, so
how did it affect you?
And so I really--
always have really connected
to these human stories.
So I came to LA
because a boyfriend
that I had in
college lived here.
And I pursued--
I thought I was going to
pursue documentary film.
And one thing led to someone--
like Victoria said-- someone
suggested I meet someone.
And suddenly I was in
post-production on the second
season of The Real World, which
is shooting in Los Angeles,
which at the time was--
it was a true documentary.
It wasn't reality TV.
It was really about the people.
And anyway, so then I
worked my way through that
and they suggested I try casting
since I was a journalist.
And they didn't-- no one knew
what casting was back then
of that.
So I did that for a while
and loved it and I--
even back then I had they did a
spinoff show called Road Rules
and it was about this group of
kids traveling across America.
And to me because the--
I also lived on a Navajo
reservation for one
of the years that I was--
after I moved to New Mexico.
And so I put the first
Native-American person on MTV
in the '90s.
And to me that was--
just made total sense
because it was the first show of
kids traveling across America.
So anyway, it's always
been part of my life.
And from there
when things became
reality TV somebody suggested
that I try narrative
and I said yes and that's
how I am here today.
Wonderful.
Wow, that's amazing.
I was an exchange student too.
Oh, wow.
In San Diego.
And I showed up in--
I come from the
dictatorship, right,
uniforms you can do
all these things.
And here are all
these girls and boys
in their swimming
suits and flip flops
and they don't have a
lot of clothes in school.
And I was appalled.
I was like, they're going
to come and get them.
This is not going to go well.
And it took me like
three months to get it
that they were not in trouble.
Anyway, we digress.
It's funny how all
of our cultural stuff
that comes with us, right?
I'm from Mexico.
And when I came
here in the summer
when I was six years old, and
in Mexico a lot of people go,
ti-ti-ti oh, yeah,
oh, yeah, ti-ti right?
And the camp
counselor looked to me
and she was like, in
America we do that.
I'm not a dog.
So that was my first
foray into, oh, OK.
This is what I do
now in Mexico yes.
Yeah.
So if somebody
says of the you go,
and so I do this in
meetings now people go,
do you have a question, Eva?
And I go, no, no I'm
agreeing with you.
Why?
Oh, and Ivette,
Ivette Rodriguez.
Tell us your story.
My story.
Hi, well, I was born in Puerto
Rico and I moved to New Jersey
to a small town in
New Jersey 45 minutes
from the city with my parents.
Actually on American airlines
with all the Rodriguezs
we all moved to this
little small town.
And I was raised-- it was very
much a working class town.
And I was-- I grew
up with Polish people
and Italian, African-American
like everybody.
Worked for
Johnson&Johnson or Ford.
So we all owned homes.
So the American dream, right?
That's what I grew up
in and then go to--
but definitely no understanding
that there was an industry.
Like I didn't understand there
was a film industry or record
industry.
The best thing you
can think of is,
you're going to become
a doctor or a lawyer
that this was what
you aspired to do.
And I was in New York
City going to school
and working as a
paralegal at a law firm.
When my name-- when my
roommate came home and told me
that she had just gone
for a job interview
with Arista Records
and she was appalled
because they weren't pay there.
I don't even remember
what the amount was
but it was not a high paying
job and she had already
graduated college.
So then I decided
that I would go,
that I would like
the opportunity
to experience a job interview.
And I went for a job interview
at 6 West 57th Street.
And when I got off
on the seventh floor,
I saw all these gold and
platinum records on the wall.
And I was like, oh, my God
where am I. I had no idea.
Growing up loving
film, loving music
but not being
sophisticated enough
to know that there
was an industry.
So at that point, I met with
my-- who became my mentor.
I interviewed with her.
And at the end of the interview,
I extended my hand to her
and I said thank you for
your time I can start Monday.
And she said, OK,
we'll see you then.
And that was the beginning of my
career at Arista Records Clive
Davis.
First artist was
Whitney Houston.
But immediately I
noticed that I was--
I didn't know I was
different actually
until I started working.
And because people wanted
my opinion about things
that I didn't understand why
because I was a Jersey girl,
rock and roll girl like why?
And it was because of
the color of my skin.
I quickly understood.
And so got to Orion
pictures, which is
why this is really full circle.
They just announced
what they do next
but Orion pictures was nearby
and I could see the posters
on the wall.
When you walk-- I would walk
for lunch and I would look up
and there's were movie
posters I was like, oh,
my God what is this?
And then, we worked
on the soundtrack
for Dying Young, Julia Roberts.
I was like a big
fan of Julia Roberts
and we get to work
on the soundtrack
because Kenny G did
the main theme song.
And I went to my
first screening,
right, to meet with the
publicity department
from the studio.
And I was like oh, my
God what is this, right?
And so I moved West.
I moved West to get
into the film industry.
And I started and I was in
the rock, in the studio.
And I quickly understood
that I was different.
Just being in meetings really
being the only brown person.
I'm aging myself.
But this is a really
long time ago.
We've come a long
way but nowhere
near where we need to be.
But I remember a feeling when
the studio executive, the head
of a studio came
to me too excited
to let me know that
he now understood
my culture because he
just got done seeing
a film about a Puerto
Rican in the south,
and like a poverty-stricken
Puerto Rican in the South
Bronx.
And he says, I really
understand your culture now.
And this is a true story.
I was like, oh, OK.
I mean, it was just like shock.
I didn't even say anything.
And people that
know me will say,
I don't believe you
didn't say anything.
I didn't say anything.
I found my voice later in life.
I was just shocked but that
has happened a lot to me.
And so I think I was always
a little activist at heart.
And actually my experience--
both of these experiences
in records and in film
actually propelled my career.
So I started my
own company in 1997
specifically called it
American entertainment mark.
Because I was like,
hello, we are American
and so it was just
to like authentically
connect with the
Latino consumer.
And-- so it's interesting
that Hollywood
has pushed where-- this
industry has pushed
me to start my own company.
And now push me to want
to produce my own films.
So this is a--
that's my story I hope.
Is that my full story?
So what movie did
you see that dude?
Oh, you're going to ask me that?
Now we're going
to know who it is?
I bet we can guess if
she tells us the year.
Because there was one movie
every five years, maybe, right?
Is a Puerto Rican movie.
Was it West Side Story?
No.
Was it Selena?
I Like It Like That.
Selena was Mexican-American.
Oh, I Like It Like That.
Sorry, charades.
Well, that leads us to
the next question, which
is about stereotypes, right?
And how-- I think Ivette
also touched on this as well,
is this just this
general perception of us.
That's either you're feisty,
you're angry, you're fiery,
what a temper, you're
so sexy, you're so hot,
you're so-- you're the
maid, you're the
you're the--
like there are all
of these stereotypes
that we all-- have
all had to deal with.
Tell us some of your stories
and we could start with Nadia.
Wow.
I think, for me
especially I came up
and I still am just
behind the camera.
As a cinematographer and someone
who like the technical side,
I think the main experience
that I had that was always
a little bit crushing was--
the minute I walked
in the room people
had no idea what
I was doing there.
It would be typically
a crew looked
like a roomful of white men.
And when I walked in it was
like, what are you doing here?
And it was this
up and down look.
A lot at my hair.
I would try to even
consider if that day I
was going to work if
it was very humid out.
How I can might not bring
so much attention to myself.
But that was something
very common that happened.
And even though
it's a look, it's
just this feeling that then sits
with you an entire day of work.
And I think something
that surprised--
I guess surprised me and
it shouldn't have was
I thought as I moved up
in experience and credits
that I would get
treated differently
but the amount of times that I'm
just completely underestimated
in my job and my
ability at times is--
Yeah, I think it just
speaks to systemically
this stereotype that is rampant
in all industries by just about
where we come from or an
intellect, our abilities.
And I think that that's
just-- that's definitely,
probably one of the
things that have--
I've had to work within
myself and within the people
that I collaborate with
the most to try and create
an environment that makes
it possible to show up
to work every day and be happy
and satisfied with the process.
Yes.
It's so funny, because I
think that is something--
we have the double whammy
because we're women
and we're people of color.
And dimming our light
when we go on a set,
especially as a director, I
remember I had a guy tell me
after I-- we finished
directing episodes, I mean,
he goes you know
you you're good.
And I was like--
What a joke.
Thank you.
He assumed weren't.
Yeah, he expected
me not to be good.
And so that dimming your
light and like I just don't--
I want to be small and not
have anybody notice me.
And I was directing
while breastfeeding.
I had just had my baby.
And I said, oh, my God
I don't want the guys--
the 90% of the crew--
to feel, I didn't want
them to feel uncomfortable.
That's-- I was worried
about them feeling as--
I was like, I'm going to have
to take breaks to pump and then
to breastfeed, da, da, da.
And it's like dimming our light.
For who?
Why?
Be your best and let
everybody deal with it.
But I've I felt that
way, too, Nadie.
You're like, ah, should
I wear my hair different.
I always thinking about
what to wear to set,
because I want to
be comfortable but I
don't want to look like a slob.
And then I'm a girl, but
I don't want to be girly.
And it's like, it's so much you
have to navigate because you
want to be seen as a boss.
And it's too much to think
about before you're even
doing the work.
That's not hard enough.
It's like we don't even know
what they feel because they've
never had to have that little
chapter of the book, which
we do.
I don't know that I've
been discriminated.
I am pretty loud
and feisty and I
tend to advocate to the
good stereotypes of who
we are as passionate women.
But I tell the story--
I would say, halfway into our
successful career at Marvel
came this man that came
to pitch as a director.
I've told this story before.
It's the story of the coffee.
And when you're about
to be interviewed
at Marvel, if you're
one of the two people
that were trying to
decide who is who,
that you get to meet
Louis, Kevin, and myself.
And usually there's the
other creative producer.
There's four of us that
will walk it through.
And you've met with
the other person,
but you haven't met
the three of us.
We were running so
late for this meeting.
And the other, the
fourth producer
had gone already to say, I'm
sorry, they're running late.
I'm sorry, the guys--
because we're always the
guys, and I'm a part of that.
And I'm OK with it.
The guys are running behind.
So finally I leave the meeting
that I'm with Kevin and Louis
and I said, you
know what, one of us
needs to show
We're way behind.
I'll go and I'll tell.
When I get there--
and I said gosh, I'm so sorry.
We're running really behind.
Have they even asked you--
do you want anything?
Can I get you anything to drink?
I want coffee.
I want coffee with milk.
And I want it now.
I said, oh.
And I thought, wow,
you are nervous.
And I'm thinking, OK,
well, let's walk over here.
The conference room was here and
there was a little coffee area
there.
But a true, true jerk.
And so I'm making the
coffee, and I'm thinking--
because I'm Argentinian.
So I battle my ego all day.
You're making the coffee?
Wait, I'm not done, Longoria.
Pará.
So I go in.
I make the coffee,
and I put in Equal.
And I don't put milk.
He wanted sugar and milk.
And he goes, god dammit, I
told you I did not want--
and I said, no, no, no,
I heard what you wanted.
This is my coffee.
Now I walked you through how
the coffee machine works.
You saw me do it.
I'm sure you were
quick to learn.
I will be right
back with the guys.
So enjoy your coffee.
And I walked out.
And that was that
moment where you can
let the ego be alive and well.
I could have said
all kinds of things.
all kinds of things
because, to be honest with
you, they were in my head.
They were all, [SOUNDS].
And I was, shh,
And I thought, you
know what, I won't
forget this moment I'm sure
he won't forget this moment.
And so I walked away.
Three of us came in,
and he was purple,
purple when I walked in.
He was like, oh my god.
Now needless to say, he pitched.
It wasn't a good pitch, and
he didn't get the job, which
is always what they asked me.
Did he get the job?
But it had nothing to do with
the fact that he was a jerk.
The pitch was not a good pitch.
But even at that moment in time
where we had made $10 billion
worth of successful films,
we had had the first Avenger
movies out.
We've had many movies.
I mean, I don't know.
I think we were
on movie number--
we're movie 30 now, which is
a different kind of success.
But at that moment
in time, on movie--
whatever-- 10 that
we were or eight,
we had the kind of success
that people talk about because,
if you have one movie
that makes a lot of money,
people talk about it.
But even at that moment
in time, the assumption
was that I was the girl,
that I would have taken notes
or I would have made him coffee.
Carmen, tell us your stories.
Well, it's interesting
listening to all of that
because I think--
because I have Peruvian
and American in my family
and in my experience,
I sort of grew up--
my mother's family's
from Queens.
And my grandfather, who
I was very close to,
was an NYPD lieutenant.
And the story was
I was his favorite.
And yet when he was introducing
me to people, he would say,
this is my Puerto
Rican granddaughter.
But he didn't know
the difference
between Puerto Rico and Peru.
It's like in the early '70s.
And my mom, his daughter, was so
mortified and mad all the time.
And I was like, it
doesn't matter to me.
Like, I love him.
He loves me.
It's fine.
So I think growing
up, feeling like,
oh, people just don't
know set the stage for me
because I don't really
notice it in a way
because I have been able to
be successful despite whatever
bias has come my way.
Lorenza, we talked
about this a little.
I have the privilege of ethnic
ambiguity, which is a thing,
too.
It's like people, they
mostly think I'm Asian.
So that experience is, I
don't know what people think.
But I know that they don't
know what I actually am most
of the time until they ask.
And so I do think I've
had privilege in that way.
And I think all of us, we have
these different privileges, as
well as these biases against
us, or if you're tall,
if you look a certain way.
So I would say that
my ethnic ambiguity
has actually given me a
lot of permission to make
a lot of moves inside the
dominant culture of Hollywood
and inside the mainstream movies
that I've worked on because I
can suggest something that
someone else would not
have suggested.
And I have actually gotten
mostly very positive response.
Like, when I say,
oh, in Bowfinger,
couldn't that
shopkeeper be Asian.
And then I present them John
Cho, and they go, oh, yeah.
But if I wasn't there and
I hadn't presented that,
it would have been white
because that's just the default.
And certainly back then,
it's much better now.
But anyway, I don't know if
that answers the question.
No, it's so funny because
I had that privilege, too,
because I didn't have an accent.
People assumed many
times that I was white.
And so they would be
like Latino, that Latino.
And I'm like, well,
I'm one of them.
Don't forget.
And they would forget.
For me, to talk about
stereotypes specifically--
because I'm listening--
I feel like we all have
the same experience.
I'm like, have I been
discriminated against because
of my ethnicity.
I think we've all
experienced a lot of sexism.
And I've spoken to a lot
of women and of color,
and they always go,
what's the cross you bear.
And they always go, oh,
definitely because I'm
a woman, not so much because
I'm a Latina woman, but a woman.
But stereotypes in the media--
so if you're talking
about storytelling,
there's two sides
of the coin and I
have two opinions about
it because I produced
a show called Devious Maids.
I produced and directed it.
And the backlash,
because I was Latina
doing a show about
maids, was like, wow,
why are you stereotyping
us again, whatever.
And if you saw the
show, the maids
were the moral
compass of the story.
And the employers were the
assholes and the idiots.
We were making a point about
how you treat domestic workers.
And I also took offense that
you think those people don't
have stories to tell--
gardeners, domestic
workers, nannies, maids.
You're saying their
lives don't matter.
So when you think about
gangbangers or things
in movies, we have to be
careful how we tell the story.
But if you give
them life and reason
and make them the point
of view in which we
are telling the story, then
that's a different thing.
If you're using them
frivolously in a movie
as a caricature of what
people think they should be,
then that's offensive.
But in storytelling,
I think it's
important to make sure that
we do tell those stories.
If you saw Demián
Bichir in A Better Life,
your heart ripped out of your
body because he was a father
trying to protect his son.
And if we humanize the
people of our community
and we give them stories and
lives that are worth telling,
then people will maybe see
them as human instead of other
and instead of from there
and instead of go back
to where you came from.
I thought, once this children
in cages on the border happened,
I thought, oh, moms
everywhere, we're
going to get so much support
because any mother knows
how that feels.
And we didn't.
And you know why?
Because we haven't
shown that these people
at the border crossing with
their children are moms.
We have to humanize
these people.
And so sometimes when you
talk about stereotypes,
when I think about it in the
narrative storytelling way,
I think we have to
tell those stories.
We can't shy away
and not tell them.
That's such a great point, Eva.
And I think it leads us
into the next question
about our invisibility, too, as
a community and the data that
has been compiled, particularly
by Stacy Smith at USC,
that in front of the
camera, behind the camera,
we're just missing.
We're 18% of the
population in this country,
and yet we are in the low
4%, 3% in terms of just
in front of the camera.
So everybody, jump in, please.
Eva, I'm sure you have a
perspective on this as well.
I have very strong perspective
on this because I think--
and I'll be quick--
but no matter
what part of the film
ecosystem we're talking about,
Latinos are vastly
underrepresented-- writer,
director, producer,
actor, casting director,
stunt coordinator, crew members,
first ACEs, camera operator.
Every part of the pipeline
you do not see Latinos.
And this is at a time where
Latinos in our country
are facing intense
concern about our safety.
We are being attacked
daily in our communities.
And so to have authentic
and accurate representation
throughout entertainment
is important.
And the interesting thing
about Stacy Smith's study
is she didn't call it
underrepresentation of Latinos
in Hollywood.
She called it the erasure of
Latino community, the erasure,
because what
happens is that void
that is happening in the
entertainment industry
is being filled by hateful,
violent rhetoric through news.
And so it's imperative
that talented storytellers
from our community are
given opportunities
to tell diverse and vibrant
narratives because it actually
boils down to our
safety in this country.
I'd also like to
make a point here
as it relates to invisibility
because really where
it all begins is that we are
absent from our history books.
So K through 12,
there is absolutely--
we're not educating
our own children
nor are we educating
other children
about our contribution.
Then you go into higher
learning-- same thing.
So we are completely erased.
And so Hollywood, that has such
an incredible opportunity to--
it actually shapes perception--
they're erasing us completely.
So therefore, that's
why, to Eva's point,
there are babies,
brown babies in cages,
and people can walk and just
sleep at night with no problem.
So it's a really large problem,
especially when you look at,
not only 18% of the population--
our purchasing power,
the fact that this
economy does not
work without American Latinos.
It just doesn't.
And also, if you look
at our population--
first of all, globe population,
let's look at the numbers.
Like, what percentage
of people in the world
are white versus the rest of us?
Like, it's just
common sense numbers.
It's business.
It's catching up with Hollywood.
So at this point, it's like, you
got to start from the very top,
like the board of
directors, the CEOs,
because it's all about money.
It's obviously
also about healing,
to be able to see us as human.
There are 60 million plus
stories in this country
alone that you're
missing out on.
And you just keep perpetuating
the same story over and over
again.
And I think that, growing
up in this environment,
I learned to code switch
at a very early age.
And I didn't even
truly understand it
until the last decade,
really understand that--
I was proud that I
could sit in a room
with a bunch of white
people and fit in because I
spoke English in a certain way.
And it wasn't until I
realized how much that really
has affected me.
I am Puerto Rican.
In my blood is African ancestry.
It is European ancestry
and Indigenous.
And I am the colonized
and the colonizer.
And so I think that we're now
coming together as Latinos
from all walks of life,
whether you're Mexican,
Puerto-- wherever it is.
And I feel like we're
coming together more now
and we're really truly not going
to ask for permission anymore.
And we're working together.
I'm seeing that.
I'm seeing a
movement in that way.
It's also that people
always think that Latinos
are the dark skinned people.
I am as Latina as they come,
but I never get involved.
I never get included.
Well, you're white, aren't you?
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Well, Argentinians
are kind of white.
I'm like, [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, that's the
other side of the coin.
Yeah, we tan well,
as you can see.
I mean, I've been out of my
yard for a long time now.
187 days, but, hey,
who's counting?
But I'm sure, Carmen, you
probably suffer some of that,
although you do have
American heritage.
But mine is Italian Spaniard.
And where do we fit in?
I mean, if I don't
say my last name,
people think I'm from Holland.
Don't ask me why.
But I've been asked if I'm
Dutch more times than Greek
or Italian or Spanish.
I mean, I don't know.
So even within our community--
I'm not just saying
white America.
I'm telling you
Latinos in America--
we don't even know how vast our
palette of shades and colors
we are.
And we tend to
exclude one another
by doing that unless
somebody sees your last name
or hears an accent.
I mean, I tick every box.
I came here very young
as an exchange student.
I was 15.
And then at 19, I moved.
I didn't speak English
when I was little.
So English is my
second language,
always has been
and always will be.
A female-- you can't deny.
It's what it is, although
I've been treated as one
of the guys my entire life.
I was always the only
female in the room
until I was able to be a part
of a group of people that
make the change so
that you no longer are,
because I also don't
understand that part of it.
There's a lot of women that
love to be the only ones.
And I'd love to have those women
come and chat with us, please.
Florencita, invite them.
OK, we'll find them.
They're easy to find.
That is not the
kind of shining star
that you should have
as a badge of honor.
And I'm gay.
So that [SOUND]
take another one.
And I have an adopted child.
[SOUND], I mean, you name it.
Bring it on.
I'm over 50.
So I'm a senior.
Don't you mess with me, girls.
I'm a senior.
So more respect.
So I mean, it's one
after the other.
But within our community, we
tend to discriminate our own
as well.
You know what I mean?
I think that may
have to do a little
with our post-colonial
legacy, too, of class and race
and all of the baggage that we
carry from the colonization.
I think the class conversation
is a big one with regard to,
why are we not
seen in Hollywood,
because who is making,
even who is making content
and who is deciding what's
important versus what's
whatever the opposite
of important is.
Their films have to
have been important.
And that's very interesting
when the group that
is making that decision
is primarily not
of color or not
upper middle class
or not all of those things.
I think it's very important
to consider all of that.
And I think, fortunately,
that's been happening.
It's been being considered.
The Academy letting all these
people in in the last few years
has been a great
step toward that.
But still, there's language.
I always think about
that, the important.
How are we deciding
who's deciding?
I want to make sure that
I pick on your phrase
the Academy letting people.
Oh my god, I was going
to say the same thing.
The Academy is inviting
people that deserve to be in.
They're not letting them in.
To say that we're
letting them in
is saying that they have
no place on earth being
[INAUDIBLE].
It goes with my feisty.
You invited me.
Here I am.
We belong.
We have a place in your table.
The Academy is now
taking a look of who
are the guests for
that dinner table.
And we are invited to join.
In fact, they can decline
the invite, by the way.
They don't have to say yes.
But I think that is
so important in part
of that is, not only the
patriarchy but in just this
and how we attack this
inclusivity and equality,
that we change how we
talk about our people
allowing us to come in.
You don't get to allow me.
And that's the thing.
It's not charity.
It's equality.
And there are many
qualified people
over the years who
are not invited.
And so I was just going
to say the same thing.
It's not like, oh, thank
you so much for letting me
in because I did
not feel that way.
I felt like, we have so many
people of talented caliber
in our community that
just aren't recognized.
The same thing with the
drama with American Dirt when
the author of that
Oprah Book Club said,
I wish somebody browner
than me wrote the book
about immigration.
And everybody in the
publishing industry,
I mean, every author
goes, it has been written.
Oprah didn't pick them.
Enrique so and so and Raquel--
like, this book has been written
18 times by a person of color.
That book was not picked
by the publishing industry.
Your book was picked.
And so that's what happens when
you don't have a Victoria that
has a seat at the table, when
you don't have a Lorenza who
has a seat at the table in
these very huge institutions
that we feel sometimes
are impenetrable.
So it's so important
that you guys are there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And, Carmen, I wasn't
picking on you.
No.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Not at all.
[INAUDIBLE] sure that you
know this is not me and you.
The words matter, every word.
Absolutely.
I completely get that.
And actually, I appreciate
that you pointed that out
because it also speaks
to maybe how did
I feel when I got invited.
It's a way to explore
your own connection to it.
But also, for me,
words do matter.
And for me, when we
talk about inclusion,
I always change it to
correcting exclusion.
I love that.
Because I don't
want to be included.
I want you to fix
that you left me out.
I love that.
I'm going to use it.
Can I use it?
Absolutely.
I love it.
I mean, but that's real.
That's the thing about language.
Language is so important with
all of this, especially for us.
Yeah, language, perspective,
and you all have--
Carmen certainly has been
fighting the good fight.
Victoria, I don't need to tell
you what a fighter that one is.
And thank god, she's
been in the room with us
and Ivette and Nadia as well.
I mean, it's been a
very interesting thing
to observe at the
Academy, how we
broaden people's perspectives,
shall we say, in a nice way.
I wanted to just
make a point, also.
It's the people in power,
they have this European POV.
And they're surrounded
by people who
look like them, talk like
them, think like them,
and have the same background.
And so that's where
we really need
to see change happen, because
we can keep talking about this.
And I've been in those
rooms as well, Carmen.
Yeah, I see that.
And it's sort of shocking.
Our perspectives
and our stories are
in a chokehold in the Hollywood
ecosystem and structure.
And so until we
are in that room,
I'm afraid we're
not going to see
the change that we need to see.
Nadia, you wanted
to say something,
and we kept cutting you off.
I'm so sorry.
No, it's interesting.
I had the an interesting
experience, even
when you mentioned the
backlash about your film.
I made a documentary
called After Maria.
And for my whole
life, I wanted to make
something that could explore
Puerto Rican identity in the US
and just the
complexity of what that
is to be a citizen of the United
States, not speak the language,
be called all types of names and
all these things and something
that I always wanted to do.
So when Hurricane
Maria happened,
I decided to make a film.
I knew I wanted to make a film
around the story of families
that were leaving the island
and coming to New York
to find a new life, not die on
the island, all the things that
were happening.
And so I ended up
telling the story.
I made a documentary
about three moms
who met on the same floor in a
FEMA hotel and the relationship
that they built
between them, trying
to survive the bureaucracy
of FEMA and the experience
that they were having.
So the film gets
greenlit by Netflix
and they take this movie.
And so, as they started to
play the trailer of the film,
there was all this
excitement around this film,
because we made it
relatively quickly.
And Puerto Rico was
still in the news,
and people were just like, I
can't wait to see this movie.
This is going to be like the
tell all film of what happened
in Puerto Rico, the exposé.
And it wasn't.
It was a character story
about three moms that
became friends and helped
raise each other's kids
and survive this experience.
But we had such a
tremendous backlash
on this film from the Puerto
Rican community mainly--
for a couple reasons.
One was people had these high
hopes of seeing themselves,
every version of
themselves, in this movie.
So people felt it should have
been this like epic eight part
Netflix series about what
happened in Hurricane Maria,
and it was not.
And so anyone that didn't
feel like their story was
represented was angry.
And then the film
was made by women
who I fell in love with that
reminded me of my own family
members, my own mother.
And there were
issues around class.
And some people felt that I
had portrayed low class Puerto
Ricans in this film.
And it was such an
interesting experiment
for me to have this
experience where
I made something
that is so dignified
and heartfelt and beautiful.
And people had all these
different interpretations
of it.
And then at the same time, I
had so many people that said,
I can't believe you
told this story.
This is so amazing.
I see myself in
this, and I've never
seen Puerto Ricans on screen
with this level of complexity.
And so what it showed
me was that there's
a huge void in
Hollywood and what
we're seeing on television,
where everyone holds
onto this idea that this
one film, which was like 38
minutes, was going
to tell everyone's
story and the disappointment
that existed when they didn't
feel like their story was
told and how much more we need
to tell stories so that
people can see themselves.
But since all of our
identities are so different,
that's not going to
happen with one film
and for platforms and
streamers and whomever
to understand that there's
also this desperate desire
to see this from an audience.
And there's so much
opportunity that's
not being given to filmmakers.
Well, you bring up such
an important point,
because if you're
the only movie,
they're going to tear it
apart for all the reasons.
When you're one of
the many movies,
then you can always reference,
well, it portrayed this well
but it didn't do it like
x movie or that movie.
But you're the only
movie to do it.
So you have nothing
but to do it right.
And it's impossible
to do it right.
That's why one of the things
that Eva said when she started
is like, I don't
want to do this one.
When I step on set, I need
to check this, this, this.
It's like, no, you
have to direct.
As long as you get
your story right,
who cares if you're wearing a
jean shirt or a regular t-shirt
or a low cut or no cut?
You know what I mean?
That kind of pressure,
it puts the spotlight on,
there is true racism
within the Latin community.
You know what I mean?
The higher class
doesn't want to be
portrayed as the lower class.
The lower class
doesn't always want
to be portrayed
as the people that
need things because a lot of
them are trying not to need it.
And I mean, it's constant.
And then my identity
as a Puerto Rican
was totally put into question.
I'm an Nuyorican from the Bronx.
I don't speak Spanish.
I'm Afro Puerto Rican.
I'm not light
skinned Puerto Rican.
What do you know?
I'm like, this is insane.
But it also was so cathartic
at the same time that--
I think once you get over
the initial processing,
I felt like I was really able
to explore something deep
within myself through
my work that I had been
wanting to do my whole life.
Yeah, I think also what
Stacy's report did also
was offer solutions
because I think sometimes
big studios are paralyzed
by this problem.
And they think, just
cast, cast, cast, cast.
And you're like, no, no, no.
We need change across casting,
building a pipeline for Latino
filmmakers, whether it's writers
or producers or directors,
urging studios to
hire Latino talent
for advertising
and the trailers.
And there's companies that
do that are Latino owned.
So making sure we're inclusive
in the entire ecosystem
of the industry
and in the industry
sectors would really help--
it would go a long way.
And I think sometimes we
only focus on casting--
like cast more, cast more.
You're like, no, no, no
We need so much more
in the infrastructure of
opportunity that has to be
created for us.
But it does go to
the some Latin kids,
young adults don't
know these doors
exist except for on camera,
because that's all they see.
They don't see what I do.
They don't see what Ivette does
or what Carmen or Nadia does.
They only see, Eva, what you
do or what you used to do.
I know you're directing,
and you've always produced.
But we need to inform
and educate our own.
I know, Ivette, you and I
and Lorenza, of course, we
do a lot of things together.
But this is why I encourage
everyone to do the panels,
go to the schools, go to
conferences, show your faces,
tell them, it happened to me.
I didn't know anybody.
And I came from far away so
that kids understand, oh, I
could do that.
Oh, I don't have to have
a 17 year degree to do it,
because I just have a
high school diploma.
It's OK.
I'll teach you.
It's all good.
You don't have to--
I mean, not to say I don't
want them to go to college.
But it's important for us to
teach the young generations
to know that you don't have to
have all the things that they
think they have to in
order to be a part of it
if you don't do it
in front of camera.
And on that note, I
know Eva has to run.
I have to go.
But I want to say,
I love you ladies.
I love you so much.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It so great talking to you.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
And now I will turn
it over to Shawn Finnie
for our final questions.
That was so amazing,
so beautiful.
Thank you all so much for coming
and just sharing your light
in your stories.
Ivette, I wanted to start with
you just because you mentioned
something about what I think
is so important in the Latino
community, is that you
are so many things.
So a lot of everyone can
be ethnically ambiguous.
Do you often-- and
for all of you--
do you feel misunderstood
because they may not
understand, Victoria,
you're from Argentina?
And Nadia, you're a Nuyorican.
And Ivette, you're this.
Do often feel
completely misunderstood
in the community as well as
people not in the community?
In the Latino community
or in the industry?
In the industry.
Yeah, they are perplexed.
They don't know quite what I am.
I think that there is a lot--
I mean I spoke about it
a little bit earlier.
But our educational
system, we are completely
erased from our history
and our contribution.
So nobody understands
the difference.
And I didn't even
know my own history
until I went out and bought a
bunch of books on Puerto Rico.
And then that's when I learned--
and then I got my DNA,
and I could see the map.
I'm like, oh, West Africa,
North Africa, here I go.
I mean, it was just
fascinating to me.
That's not something I
learned in a history book
or in advanced learning.
And [INAUDIBLE]
so we don't have.
And I'm really excited
about, fingers crossed,
the American Latino
museum on the Hill.
That's going to be a
beautiful place where people
can come and learn about
our culture and our history
and in Hollywood.
Hollywood could help
us get there quicker
because everything else
is going to take a minute.
But Hollywood has
the power right now,
right here to make a
difference and to help
us tell our stories so that
people aren't afraid of us
and they're not stereotyping us.
So really, it's Hollywood.
I'm talking to Hollywood.
This is not rocket science.
It's really not.
I think it's important not to
dilute your story to blend in.
And I think what we've
been trying to do
for so long is to blend in.
Why?
Because it's better that way.
If you blend in, they're
not going to single you out.
And you can't not
blend in this female.
If that's how you
define yourself,
then you have to just
blend in every other way.
And you're going to have enough.
You're going to be
discriminated as a female.
So just shut up.
Don't sit.
Just, if you have an
accent, work on it so people
don't hear it.
I refuse to work on my accent.
It is what it is.
Either you like it or you
don't like it, I love it.
And don't get me
pissed off because I'll
start rattling in Spanish,
and I'll just say it all.
And that's just how it goes.
Lorenza, [SPEAKING SPANISH].
It's just how it goes.
I mean, so many
times people say--
I love it when you start
singing in Spanish.
I do.
People used to say to
me, are you Italian,
and that invite, that sexy
invite to say, yes, yes, yes,
so that we can actually--
I'm like, well, my
grandparents were.
But, no, I am full
on Argentinian.
And that was [SOUND].
And Victoria, do
you remember when
it was the Italians
and the Irish who
were discriminated against?
So that's the interesting thing.
Now they're cool.
Totally.
Everything has a flow.
But I think that the more of
us that are out there talking
about it, the more of our
stories, the more times
that Nadia gets to tell
that story that Puerto Rican
or Nuyorican, however you
want to call it, Nadia--
and maybe in your next film,
you tell the other story
After Maria because
those were three mothers.
There were thousands--
thousands-- that were affected.
And maybe is there one
after the earthquake.
Who knows?
But you told a different
story would be coming.
And it's always enriching the
fact that, behind that camera,
there is a person
that represents us.
You know what I mean?
And then we can talk
about it, and the minute
that people see it,
that it happened to you,
and it happened to me, and
Lorenza and Carmen and Ivette
and Eva and many others--
you don't have to be Penelope
Cruz or Salma Hayek or Eva
Longoria.
There's other women out
there that are doing it.
And that's the most
important thing.
You can be in any other
place in the film industry.
And there's so many
places that you
can be to make a difference.
Absolutely.
And I do think--
to speak, Victoria,
to what you were saying.
Specificity-- for me it's been
very exciting in these last,
I think, only really
five years to see
these voices telling their
own stories, our own stories.
And I think until there is real
specificity to the narratives,
it is going to be like,
oh, here's a cast.
Make the supporting person
Latin or make her Black.
And even for me,
who is all about,
as I said, correcting
exclusion, I
don't find that to be
any kind of solution.
I actually find that
to be somewhat--
I don't want to say racist.
But it doesn't
solve any problems.
But it makes people feel
like something has happened.
And I don't like
participating in that.
If there's a story reason
for the supporting character
to be Latin or Black,
then fantastic.
Or if you're going to
change that story, if you're
going to enrich that character
in a way that is specific, then
great.
But when you get these
storytellers telling
their own stories,
that doesn't have
to happen because it's natural.
It's natural to the
story, just like it
is natural in our actual lives.
Are you saying that
you'd rather not
have those supporting
roles be of people of color
because it's not
necessarily that story
that they're telling?
I prefer if that-- and this
is something that I generally
try to do, and I'm pretty
successful with it--
in having a dialogue
with the filmmakers
and saying like, great,
yes, but is there something
that makes this relevant.
I also agree with
trying to just make
the entire thing more diverse.
And it doesn't have
to be specific.
But I'm saying for
us to move forward,
even just a little tweak
of, give that person
a reason to have been Latin
at the JPL or whatever, again,
because I think it does
speak to the specific--
I agree with you, Carmen.
And actually, we both--
I worked on Vida
on second season.
I mean, you did an
amazing job with Vida.
But for me as a marketer,
talking to our media
and having to really talk to
all the organizations and say,
I do not want you to
come out and start
talking about the fact that
this is a story about LGBTQ
and that's East Los An--
I literally had to
speak to them in advance
to say, do not come out and
just-- this one story is
a very specific story that
was so beautifully told,
that it's not everybody's story.
And so specifically what you
did with that specific show,
I mean, I loved it.
I love every character
in that series.
They're amazing.
Thank you.
It's a stories about sisters.
I think it is.
I think it's about
allowing ourselves
to be our full selves.
And in that one it is.
It's about being sisters.
That story is about
being sisters.
That's it.
It's universal.
It's so universal.
And the fact [INAUDIBLE] and one
is gay and the other one is not
and then the mother--
we're sisters.
And I think that people
love to pigeonhole us
into the one thing.
And I understand
they have to sell it.
And I understand they have
to, in this moment in time,
they have to look good and
say, no, no, we are inclusive
or we're trying to correct
exclusion, as Carmen says.
That's my favorite line of
it all, the whole day today.
I'm so glad that I heard it.
But I think it's important
that, can we just be women.
Can we just be moms,
sisters, partners, friends?
And then the moment
that we start
taking the things that
makes us so different,
we start belonging.
And we tell that to ourselves
and we tell that to society.
If you look at every single
Netflix show that is here now
from every country--
I've seen them all
because I see everything
from all over the world--
we're not that different.
We all have the same problems.
Absolutely.
Of course.
I mean, we speak
another language.
We may look a little different.
But truly, it's about
the pursuit of happiness,
the lack of friendship, the need
to decide, the fear of dying.
I mean, I can go on and on.
It's universal.
Absolutely.
It's very much universal.
And Netflix is such
a great platform.
I watch all of the same.
I love it so much.
I mean, I'm watching
every country,
and I always think to
myself, Hollywood studios,
why, why can't you do this.
Why can't you look at
what Netflix is doing?
It's amazing.
I mean, it's right
there for you just
to understand that there is an
audience, a global audience.
I think slowly but surely
everyone is getting the--
they're hearing
the bell, which has
been ringing for a long time.
A long time.
But you say something, Victoria,
that I know I'll never forget
and that's, until
we're 30% of the room,
we're really not
going to see a change.
We don't turn the room.
I always say that you can be
the one person or the 2% or 3%.
The problem is 30%
has enough weight
to start changing
the conversation.
You still can be toppled
by the other 70%.
But when you're just one
voice in a room where
there's 10 people, you're
just one single voice.
And then you're two.
Then it's just that pair
that is always [SOUNDS]..
Then all of a sudden there's
three people talking about it.
So it's not just the rattlers.
There's somebody else.
And then somebody in
the room, again, of 10
finds themselves
to have permission
to hear what you're saying.
They allow themselves to hear
it because more than one person
says it.
And then you turn to
start to be heard.
You may be being listened to.
But if you're not
heard, you're not
going to turn the room
to where it needs to
or, if nothing
else, to be heard.
Sometimes we just want
you to consider it.
Like Carmen is saying,
consider not excluding us.
Just consider it.
Consider giving that character
a backstory as opposed to Latin
boy 17.
Just consider it.
And that to me is part
of why, not only are
we talking about it in all these
rooms, but people are listening
and we're being heard, which is
the next step to just listening
because you politically
have to do it.
Yes, that's right.
I think what's interesting about
the 30% is that, for me, that
feels like it's going
to take a long time,
because we have to
have a pipeline.
And these people have
to have experience.
And we have to really build it.
And that's hopefully
what's happening.
Don't get caught
up on the pipeline.
We built a studio
without knowing nothing
about how to do it.
And that's how Marvel
Studio was born.
Please, don't get caught up on
the, we would-- no, just do it.
Just do it, please.
Do it.
Get out there.
I mean, I think we
are all doing it.
I think everyone else
has to come on board.
That's the thing.
They have to do it.
And I want to say that one
thing that LA Collab is
during his meeting with studios.
And they are looking.
There are a lot of Latinos
that are qualified,
guys, for these jobs, FYI.
So I do believe in the
pipeline and all that.
But really, there's a lot of us.
And so what I'm seeing
is that a lot of them
are open to having
this conversation.
We are collecting resumes
and sending them their way.
So there are a lot of
Latinos that are ready.
So I think it's important.
I had a conversation
with the head
of a studio that reached out
for me to possibly come inside
and leave my company.
And one of the things--
he wanted to sit with me
and ask me why certain
films didn't work.
And when he brought up
this film and I told him,
his face dropped.
And he was shocked.
He was absolutely shocked
at and why didn't anybody
tell me that.
And I said, because no one
looked like me in the room.
And this is exactly what.
You're making decisions
without us in the room.
It's just you're leaving
money on the table.
It's really simple.
It's not fiscally
responsible, is it?
No, it isn't.
Yeah, it's silly.
Well, mujeres,
thank you so much.
This has been so incredible.
I know we could sit here and
talk for hours and hours.
And we have to do that at
some point once COVID ends.
We'll do it in person.
I just want to
thank you so much.
What an amazing group of women.
I'm so proud.
And I'm so happy
that you're all here.
Hi, I'm Carmen Cuba.
Thank you for watching
Academy Dialogues.